[yells]
[growls]
[both grunting]
[yells]
Ah!
Ahh.
[growls]
[grunting]
[yells]
[all yelling]
[all yelling halfheartedly]
[yelling]
Yeah, uh.
[panting]
[growls]
[babbling in a high voice]
[all yelling]
Ha ha ha!
[growls]
[yells]
Oh, no.
[all grunting disapprovingly]
Uh...
Oh.
Oh...ah!
[all cheering]
(all)
[questioning grunts]
[straining]
[imitating baby crying]
[all grunting disapprovingly]
Wha--ah, ah?
[all grumbling]
Huh.
Ah.
Uh...
[grunts]
[babbling grunts]
[all cheering]
[grunting]
[all murmuring]
[all cheering]
[grunts]
[all grunting disapprovingly]
[all cheering]
[all cheering briefly]
Ah.
Ah?
[babbling grunts]
Ah--uh...
Uh...
[mumbling]
[continues mumbling]
Ah. Ah.
[clears throat]
Ah.
Ah!
[all cheering]
[all laughing and cheering]
[grunting rhythmically]
[all cheering]
Ah.
Ah!
Oh.